all right candy candy uh where you from
originally where didd you grow up I grew
up in Pasadena
California tell me about your family um
my family my mom is a single mother um
there's four of us four girls no
Brothers U my mom's um came from
Guatemala when she was about 16 years
old and she's been working you know ever
since then you know to make sure that we
had a good um childhood how would you
describe your childhood um I would
describe
it that it was it was good you know my
mom tried the best that she could she
was always working so I was always be at
the babysitters and stuff but I knew
that my mom was always trying to make um
make a stable like household for me and
my sisters even though she was a single
momh no abuse anything like that U my
mom was um she kind of drinks here and
there but she's like a um she's a stable
stable worker even though she has like
her little um habit but um
yeah what kind of girl were you in high
school I was ugly and like a loser I was
just shy um I didn't really talk to no
boys or nothing um yeah I was like a
good girl I guess but um I had no
friends yeah you graduated yeah I
graduated from high school thank God mhm
and drugs came into your life at some
point drugs came into my life when I
turned about 18 um I got my first job in
Pasadena at style 7 and um I met a guy
through my one of my friends and um we
started talking and he was a little
older than me and at the time I was
naive I didn't know anything about like
OPI drugs anything like that so when he
was coming around and I would see him
high I was just curious to know the
feeling of it so one day I tried the um
the perk 30s was what I started with um
one day I tried it and ever since then I
I just been using drugs
and it's been like like a really like a
roller coaster you know like um at the
beginning of the time of first using it
was really bad you know like my family
they're still hurting you know but it's
I don't want to say they're used to it
now but like
um it's just like it is what it is I
guess now but like at first it was just
like really hard and stuff you know like
I ended up like leaving my house cuz I
knew I was hurting my mom and my family
you know so that led me to be
outside and then being outside just like
that to me using like getting introduced
to like fat
off and then when I got introdu
sorry I got introduce the F
all and ever since then I've been using
it and um it was like a roller coaster
like I said but um I've gotten
help at at first I didn't think I needed
help cuz I didn't see a problem and what
I was doing you know but as I started
being outside more like I guess learning
the streets and having to like teach
myself like I had to get myself and pull
myself out of that hole and it was hard
because like I said I left my house and
out outside and people out here are not
nice and honest you know they're like
mean and evil you know and they and they
want to corrupt you so me being like I
would always say like I'm just like the
um the angel of the streets cuz like I
wouldn't never let no situation like
make me a bad person even though like
you would think you would because the
streets do make you a grimy person but
if you if you're not in your heart it
won't change you but a lot of people do
change but yeah so um yeah I was living
in a tent with one a guy I met with
whatever we were dating for like about a
year we were just on the streets
whatever um going to house to house
couch to couch and then um we were at a
tent and finally um there was like some
people from people's concern they came
up to the tent and were asking like you
guys homeless you guys need help and I
was like yeah so when I finally got the
help and the opportunity to like change
and like get myself pulled out the
situation I I went for it you know and
um I showed up to the tent when they
told me to go back and show up so they
could take me into housing and they took
me in and I was in a living in a hotel
for about like 2 years and in those two
years like I was able to I I'm still
using drugs but um I was able to like
not be so um what's the word like
um like so blinded with it you know like
like my like I know I'm still using but
I'm not as like blind and naive as I was
in the beginning like I could see more
clearly now and like I can see that the
drugs are enough for me you know like
God has bigger and better things planned
for me and I need to like realize that
and like listen more to what he's saying
because I'm just blessed that I'm still
here right now being through what I've
been through you know like there's a lot
of people and a lot of girls that told
me situation that they've been in and
thank God that that's never happened to
me so I don't know it's just been like
what is your drug now fentanyl yeah I
use fentanyl right now yeah but right
now like I'm trying to teach myself to
like um separate myself from it not
being so like hooked on it CU back then
I used to have to smoke every second you
know like I would have to go to the
restroom or always disappearing you know
like just like weird you know thinking
no one's going to notice and stuff like
you know everybody noticed everybody
noticed and then when I started noticing
that everybody noticed that's when I had
to check myself and be like girl what
are you doing you know like this is not
for you you're not only hurting yourself
I'm hurting my mom and my
sisters and I have a little sister that
followed in my footsteps so it
just I just feel like I just need to
make things right now you know I can't I
need to stop being selfish
and you know getting high and stuff now
that I'm seeing it through like a
sibling it's just totally different you
know like it's just a whole different
perspective and like I don't want it
it's not for me it's not for her and I
got nothing against it you know I don't
judge at all but to each their own but I
think that God put me here to um guide
my sisters into the right place you have
a younger sister who's using
yeah yeah how have you made money while
you've been on the streets um I used to
boost I would have to steal um and there
would be times where where I would you
know
like I used to work in the club the
strip club to make my money and stuff
you know whatever I could get like my
hands on you know to make some
money yeah tell me about you've been
staying on Skid Row yeah actually um
it's crazy cuz um you would think like
I'm getting housed right so I would get
house somewhere else they housed me on
SK road so it just made my story even
more like crazy like I already with
through the homeless stage and being
outside so I'm thinking yeah I'm going
get house you know New Beginnings like
get out of the environment no like it's
like the devil is real they house me on
skid road so right now this is the
battle where I got to be strong and tell
myself okay is this what you want
because it's not going to get any better
than what it's it's all around me you
know that you can't get any clearer than
that so I feel like God put me here to
show me like this is not for you you can
have more than this
you know I'm not saying I'm better than
anybody because I'm not perfect at all
but I do believe in God and I feel like
God you know has something better
planned tell me about being a female on
SK row oh my
God being a female on skid road is crazy
like I feel like I can't walk anywhere
down the street around the corner like
I'm always getting like harassed or like
car stopping trying to get me in the car
like stuff like that you know it just
like I just can never just go for a walk
around here like it's literally always
like something you know like and it just
makes me feel really uncomfortable
and I don't know it's just like it's
just not fair you know like I just want
to walk down the street and I can't you
know but what's your biggest regret now
my biggest regret is trying the drug
that my ex-boyfriend was on I regret
trying it I wish I was Stronger at the
time and I wish I was strong enough to
leave him when I was first seeing it cuz
when I first seen it I didn't know any
of it you know it was new to me and I I
was like why is he always sleepy like
what's you know what's going on and then
but obviously when you get in love your
first love you're stupid and blind right
so I went back to him when I went back
that's when I tried the perk and I went
from sniffing the perk ass sets to
smoking it on a foil and then from
smoking that on foil that's when I got
introduced to Fentanyl and now I'm
smoking fit and all how old are you now
I'm 26
26 do you have friends no my dog's my
friend your
dog emotionally what do you go through
living this
life feel
lost I feel lost but not completely lost
because
like like I'm still here you know like
there's a lot of people that I've met in
the journey being outside and being in
drug there's a lot of people that I've
met that just started using and they're
not even there anymore you know like
mentally and physically so I'm just like
like there has to be a purpose more for
me because I'm still here through
everything
and I don't feel like I should
be I feel like I've been playing with
myself and and like
just I don't want you know I don't want
to die I don't at first I wanted
to but then like see my sister and you
know I have to be like the strong one
and be the one to um put my foot down
and I never thought I would even be
saying something like this you know I
always thought like like I'm going to
just be a drug addict you know that's
just what it is now like I'm hooked on
drugs I'm yeah that's what I thought but
then I'm like no I can't I can't like
down myself like that you know like
there there's something there like you
know like so I just had to listen to
that voice that was deep and really low
in my head and once I started doing that
things little things started like you
know getting better everything is still
like roller coaster I do have my ups and
downs but like right now like I'm doing
way better than I was before and I have
my sister with me now you know she's
safe with me and that's the main thing
that had me worry too was we would
always get separated when we be outside
you know and it would scare me because
like I said everybody out here is not
like they're not good people
and I just be worried that one day one
of us you
know won't be there
and so is that your biggest fear
yeah yeah it is and it's like if you a
deed you know what only Ed once which is
really crazy I Ed once because my
boyfriend because I was at work at the
time and my boyfriend whatever was doing
what he was doing and he picked up his
little stash and he did his own stash
right so when I'm getting off work I'm
going to go pick up my
stash and he was just like um you know
hounding on it and at the time you know
I was just using so I was like kind of
like feeling for it you know so when he
was trying to like get on my on my sack
I was like no you know so I kind of like
sniffed it all at once and I did
overdose that one time but it was only
because
like I was being stupid and overdoing
you know the
drug but there's I don't know there's
not really no like limit with this drug
either like it takes like the littlest
bit to like to kill you you know like
that's why I'm just like feel like I've
been playing with my my life and I need
to stop doing that cuz not everyone's
lucky like how I am did you have dreams
of doing something else with your life
when you were young yes um I wanted to
be a
cosmetologist um I love doing hair and
makeup and I love making people feel
beautiful and and good about themselves
because it makes me feel good well
you're still young enough to to do that
yeah yeah I am I want to that's what I
want the end of the story to be is I
became a cosmetologist and and me and my
sister are sober and back with my family
and we're
just that's what I
want what would you like to be in five
years I would like to be in 5
years hopefully be licensed a licensed
cosmetologist by then and in a big house
with my mom and my sisters again that's
what I
want
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your
life to not play with my life to not
play with it because it is real people
do die and there's no coming back when
that's
done and I've learned that being outside
like lost a lot of people at a very
young age and it's just sad because it's
like we're all
lost
but you only change if you really want
change that's one thing I did learn in
this whole situation is that if you want
change you can change that's one
thing that's one
thing all right candy thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you for
having me wish you lots of luck I hope
you get away from here yeah that's going
to be the um end of the story excellent
thank you thank
you